imagine this is a hydrogen atom this is
another one and then this is h2 the
hydrogen molecule you can break it apart
add an oxygen atom and you make h2o
water the carbon with four hydrogen's
that is methane and you can actually
combine it with water to make methanol
these are snaps the magnetic molecular
modeling kit and I am Derek Muller the
creator of a youtube channel called
veritasium which has nearly three
million subscribers through my videos I
teach science virtually to millions of
people around the world but some things
are best learned hands-on like chemistry
I mean atoms are impossible to see and
chemical notation can be very confusing
for students and that's why as a teacher
for seven years before I started
veritasium I always wish that something
like this existed soeun atoms are an
improvement over ball and stick models
for three reasons
they are quicker to put together and
break apart plus they are a better
representation of what a molecule
actually looks like I mean bonds are not
sticks they are overlapping electron
orbitals and most important SNAT UM's
allow you to feel the attraction between
atoms and that helps break the
misconception that bonds store energy
this is something that I talked to Hank
green about on scishow talk show where
is the energy coming from the bonds man
but my concern is this right if you
think that there really is energy in
bonds yeah then you would imagine
something like breaking those bonds open
releases that energy right which is
totally false that is true
this is my point the formation of bonds
that releases energy and is the breaking
of bonds which takes energy widths
knatoms you can easily feel the work you
need to do to break a bond and you can
hear the energy released when a new bond
forms I have been developing statins for
over two years the first prototypes I
made out of styrofoam balls that I cut
and put magnets in you may have seen
this picture on my Instagram then I made
drawings for the product and had them 3d
printed and then I created some
injection molded prototypes which I
spray-painted and used in my video five
fun physics phenomena now I need your
help to make this project a reality
veritasium has shown me there are
millions of people out there
about helping others understand science
so if you agree with me that this would
help thats Natomas should exist in the
world then help me fund the production
molds and magnets required to make this
happen
a basics knatoms kit would include six
carbon atoms six oxygens and 12
hydrogens that's all the atoms you need
to make glucose the basic sugar molecule
but of course with these building blocks
you could build hundreds of other
molecules and I will make some video
guides explaining how to use statins to
learn about molecules chemical bonding
geometry and balancing equations and if
we reach a stretch target I will add
another element to the kit like nitrogen
plus if we reach a further stretch
target I will build an app that will
gamify the process of learning allowing
users to learn about new molecules and
capture their progress I think the best
way to learn science is hands-on from a
young age and if you want to help me
make this happen then support this
Kickstarter you don't have to buy a set
of statins though that definitely would
help if you think it's a good idea just
share it with your friends on Twitter or
Facebook I really appreciate your
support and I look forward to helping
the world learn science physically in
addition to through the internet